que prévu pour rebrancher les
abonnés. Le résultat c'est que
les gens maintenant manquent
d'électricité depuis 72 heures.
- L'opération nettoyage est
en branle chez Natacha Patry.
Les orages violents de samedi
ont déraciné plusieurs pins qui
se sont abattu% sa maison,
mais le pire a été évité.
NATACHA PATRY
- J'attends l'évaluateur,
le contracteur des assurances
s'en vient. J'ai le gars
de bardeaux qui s'en vient.
- Un peu plus loin,
une autre maison et une voiture
endommagées. Ici, le toit
d'un cabanon est complètement
démoli, une partie de la clôture
arrachée.
LUCIE GOSSELIN
- Les assurances, je ne sais pas
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont payer,
ça discute beaucoup, même si
ça fait 40 ans qu'on paye
nos assurances.
- Les travailleurs d'Hydro-
Québec rétablissent le courant
dans cette rue alors que
les résidents commencent
à s'impatienter.
PIERRE SCHNEIDER
- Ce n'est pas chaud parce
qu'évidemment, il n'y a pas
de courant, puis on a tout perdu
notre nourriture, et puis
on trouve ça... On commence la
quatrième journée, on commence
à trouver ça dur.
- La société d'État espérait
ce matin rebrancher la grande
majorité de ses clients d'ici
la fin de la soirée, mais
ce sera probablement plus long
qu'anticipé.
- Je commence à trouver ça
très long.
JACQUES GARIÉPY,
maire de Saint-Sauveur
- Hydro-Québec, on les voit,
ils ont ici mais ils travaillent
en silo, Hydro-Quéa
pas de communication avec eux.
- Beaucoup d'arbres et de
branches sont tombés sur
les fils : il faut diX,Od tout
dégager. L'ampleur du travail
est immense.
- C'est sûr que c'est spécial.
Je travaille avec des gars qui
sont là depuis 15 ans et plus
et dans le secteur ici, on n'a
comme jamais vu ça. On a souvent
des arbr@Xignes,
mais là, les arbres ont passé
à tabac, ils ont scrapé
les poteaux.
JONATAN JULIEN, ministre Énergie
es naturelles, Québec
- On fait toujours des
projections de rétablissement.
On n'atteint pas exactement
nos cibles actuellement parce
que l'expérience et la situation
actuelleactuelleactuelleactuell.
Dans les Hautes-Laurentides,
ce n'est pas des branches,
c'est des troncs. Les équipes
travaillent d'arrache-pied.
- Entre-temps, à Saint-Sauveur,e
communautaire pour les
sinistrés. Ils peuvent recharger
leurs appareils électroniques
ou encore prendre une douche.
- Je viens ici pour recharger
tous nos appareils, puis faire
les appels.
- Et on distribue aussi de l'eau
potable à ceux qui en ontbesoin.
LISE CARBONNEAU
- On a un puits, un puits; donc
pas d'électricité, pas d'eau.- s
d'attente devant plusieurs
stations-service.
- Mettre du gaz pour la
génératrice parce qu'on n'a pas
le choix, on ne sait même pas
pour combien de temps
on va en avoir encore.
- S'approvisionner n'a pas été
- Il n'y avait pas de carte de
débit, pas de carte de crédit
qui marchaient, ça fait que
c'était comptant, ça fait qu'on
a vu beaucoup de... beaucoup
de gens en détresse, pas de gaz
dans l'auto, pas d'argent
comptant...
On sait pas quoi faire.
- C'est la même histoire